nice to see you again and congrats on
the move thanks
um so um this is a jokey question but
when you got to set on the first day of
filming you see jessica's commitment uh
and we sort of just like i just need to
turn the camera on this is gonna be
great
are you is it a jokey question or is
that a serious question
uh no i'm joking around because
obviously you're an integral part of
making the movie but i'm just saying
oh all i have to do is just point the
camera at jessica and and
and we're good to go
pretty much yeah yeah um
yeah basically yeah that's what it was
yeah okay
the horrible way to start the interview
i was just trying to make a joke about
how good she was in the movie i know i
totally agree no i i i mean it's funny
because i mean i honestly where my my
where my head went was
getting to the place where the makeup
was right
meaning you know you don't think this is
something i've never worked with
prosthetics before i've never done a
project where prosthetics were so
integral
to the to the to the movie
um i don't even know if i've ever really
done any real prosthetics at all but
anyway
you don't really think about the trial
and error that goes into it to get the
prosthetics to where they work you think
maybe it's just you know
kind of you get someone who knows what
they're doing and then they put some
prosthetics on you and you're good to go
but it's it's a really
incredibly detailed and and
tricky process of fitting
these very delicate
handmade
moldings to the actor's face
to change the shape of the face a little
bit while still giving the actor enough
mobility in their face
to give a performance so that they don't
get just buried inside the the
prosthetics
and um it's very time
intensive so it you don't it isn't like
if you do the cheeks and they don't look
right two minutes later you get to try
it again it's like it takes they have to
make a brand new mold it takes weeks for
the for them to get the mold back from
the lab and da da so
you know there's
the honest answer the question is is by
by the time we actually saw
the character in the prosthetics with
the makeup with the hair
and the wardrobe we had already
collectively been through a lot of sort
of like trial and error to get to that
place
and um
in addition to having recorded a lot of
the music was the very first thing we
did way before we even started prep was
we recorded all those songs
and so um
by the time we actually were there on
day one like we'd sort of like met
i'd like met tammy faye already a few
times
um you know but like you so it's sort of
like
each piece comes together and you sort
of are like incrementally getting a
clearer sense of like who this character
is going to be
um but you never especially with the
prosthetics you actually didn't know
until the first day like if it was even
gonna work
fully so that it was exciting when we go
oh my god that's it you look like her
that's perfect
on that note i already have to stop i'm
just gonna say i got one question i'm
gonna say congratulations i thought you
did a great job with this thank you so
much appreciate it cool have a great day
you too